le sport comme chaque lundi et anthony
c'est la dernière page de sport de
l'année 2012
oui tout à fait c'est pas la dernière
page de ce sport tout court même si on
approche du 21 décembre
les mayas pressions en tout cas la
semaine prochaine ce sera une série à
2,5 édition spéciale du 7 8 pour faire
le point sur 2012 aussi évoqué lé
dossier de 2013 cinq émissions cinq
thématiques à partir de la semaine
prochaine le 7 8 en direct fera une
petite pause
on passe donc aux sports wii et pour
cette dernière chronique l'année 2012 on
est plutôt bien entouré
thierry fabre le président du tout
nouveau club de vélo de d'elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir à vous
et à mes côtés deux joueuses de
l'entente au chesnay versailles 1 cette
équipe presque ainsi on peut presque les
apps il est presque braqueuses mais
puisque c'est du basket dont il s'agît
voilà c'est du basket un tout à fait les
braqueuses inquiet qui avaient fait de
très beaux de très beaux jeux leila
lachgar et virginie aurensan bonsoir à
toutes les deux on parlera avec vous
dans la deuxième partie de la chronique
de votre bilan de ma première moitié de
saison voilà et alors on va revenir tout
de suite au vélo et à cette création de
nouveaux clubs
enfin nouveau club le terme est un peu
biaisé puisque le vélo-club maurepas
elancourt existait déjà c'est juste le
nom qui change c'est ça thierry tout à
fait voeu club marpen en cours avec 39
ans on a décidé de changer de nom pour
se rapprocher de saint quentin en
yvelines et des longs cours donc pour
créer un club compétition parce qu'on
est le seul club de compétition sur
saint quentin en yvelines
vous avez 90 compétiteurs après on a à
peu près 100 adhérents
avec 15 motards c'est un peu particulier
par rapport aux motards donc on est
affiliée à trois fédérations la
fédération française de cyclisme
la fsgt et l'ufolep voilà avec quinze
jeunes et nous avons des gens diplômés
qui encadre les gamins dès samedi
après-midi sur route et une mercredi en
vtt
mais là le changement de nom de passer
de vélo club de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est le but c'est de véritablement
s'implanter dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin ou c'est juste pour mieux
refléter une réalité actuelle qui est
qu'aujourd'hui c'était trop limité de
dire vélo-club d'elancourt maurepas oui
beaucoup de choses qui se sont bousculés
beaucoup de choses qui nous ont fait
changer changer d'identité
la première c'est le rapport moral que
nous avons avec 50 ans ni vinyle service
des sports de l'agglomération
la communauté de communes et d'elancourt
la deuxième chose on vient d'avoir une
marraine cette marraine isabelle moteur
j'appelle la cité voilà qui est donc
directrice béatrice technique national
de la chanson française de cyclisme
si on rapporte pas si enfin un petit
comparatif ci par exemple elancourt
avait un parent ça serait aimé jacquet
voilà donc isabelle gautheron c'est la
dtn et puis c'est aussi l'ancien record
man woman du monde du 200 m lancé sur un
geste un an 200 m lancé 500 mètres lancé
elle a été multiple championne de france
de vitesse force et pas n'importe qui
quand elle a fait quatrième aux jeux de
sydney et isabelle jeudi dernier vient
de signer sa licence ou vicieux sky
vélo-club elancourt saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est une petite fierté déjà pour vous
petite chérie et alors vous voulez
profiter aussi du dynamisme apporté par
le par le vélodrome dont on voit les
évolutions chaque jour ouais il ya le
vélodrome d'un côté la colline de
l'autre alors le vélodrome
isabelle en signant chez nous nous a
fait une petite promesse de nous faire
découvrir la piste
je pense qu'elle a peut-être une idée
derrière la tête pour une future
création d'une section piste et nous
c'est notre objectif
parce que vous êtes plus spécialisés
route et métal
marche vtt et cyclo cross actuellement à
vélodrome dont d'ailleurs il sera
question lors d'une des éditions
spéciales de cette huître la semaine
prochaine vous fera un point complet sur
ce chantier
oui et puis aussi à côté de cette
section piste il ya la priorité que vous
allez donner à la formation à la
formation des jeunes notamment
tout à fait alors il veut quelque chose
d'exceptionnel tout arrive en même temps
un changement de nom une marraine de
qualité et la mairie d'elancourt qui qui
a mis les moyens qui vient de nous
offrir un local de 90 m² pour l'instant
on ne peut pas se réunir demande dedans
parce que ce n'est pas sain de rp donc
il ya une étude qui est fait par la
mairie pour justement passé ce dock laon
le rp on a recours c'est un
établissement recevant du public
d'accord on peut voir faire des réunions
on peut pas ouvrir l'école de cyclisme
et l'objectif c'est d'ouvrir une école
de 6,8 sur saint quentin pour accueillir
des enfants à partir de 6 ans parce que
justement les enfants ça va être les ce
sont les racines et les fondamentaux de
notre club
quoi voilà et puis c'est important que
dans un an à peu près jour pour jour un
le vélodrome va ouvrir ses portes qu'il
y ait une base une structure entier
entité saint quentin en yvelines qui
soit présente à côté du vélodrome et
qu'ils puissent bénéficier de la piste
exceptionnel qui aura de l'espace bmx
etc
voilà nous mais nous on est ouvert à
tout ça on est ouvert tout ça parce
qu'en plus on a déjà des des
compétiteurs qui sont qui sont déjà
venus cette année avec l'idée de faire
de la piste et c'est rare de nos jours
donc on va j'espère qu'on va nous donner
l'occasion avec isabelle de profiter de
ce joyau soyaux et puis il ya aussi le
vtt avec la colline
donc ça c'est
une autre histoire mais la colline c'est
entre parenthèses comme ça et bien on
organise depuis 15 ans la revancharde
c'est notre bébé c'est donc depuis
quinze ans vous nous soutenez par
rapport aux images et à vos commentaires
on vous en remercie et on envoie
quelques années cette affaire on est en
dedans nous en chaque édition c'est long
plus c'est pour nos orphelins mais c'est
bien tout ça pour convier
professionnelle que donc c'est pour nos
orphelins tous les ans juste une petite
aparté c'était sur un lieu le 30 juin et
depuis 15 ans on a reversé à l'oeuvre
des pupilles et environ 45 euros
voilà c'est un petit choc que je vous
donne donc on va faire 1 1 15e
anniversaire est donc cette colline et
bien on la façonnent on la construit on
la nettoierons l'adepo lui si notre
terrain de jeu quoi voilà est alors en
attendant l'ouverture de ce joyau comme
vous dites du vélodrome les prochaines
dates
outre le outre la revancharde en 2013
quelles sont elles
alors sportivement on a des jeunes
et qui vont se rendre en bretagne cap
fréhel au championnat fédéral de
cyclo-cross fsgt nos deux gaps la france
je vais à de france est clair faire
puisque france c'est pour la fsc
voilà donc ces fédéral donc on est
obligé de porter ce nom là on a des
gamins qui sont les favoris dont
catégorie 15 ans ça a fait un pas trop
trop en parler parce qu'on sort soit
laissée se préparer tranquillement
tranquillement surtout que l'année
dernière avec le vc mes anciens clubs
comme nous l'avions on a quand même
ramené le premier titre de champion
national sur route ufolep avec adrien
garay mais c'est la première fois qu'on
a un maillot bleu blanc de chez nous ça
a parfois sur 51 de tous les clubs qui
existent quoi voilà et on en est fiers
de bons résultats et encore de beaux
résultats
les deux grands lacs voir elle
exactement bien progresser merci
beaucoup thiery latt une petite aparté
je profite que les deux jeunes filles
soient côté d'elle nous donc on a quand
même personnel
on a quand même des féminines chez nous
pour être je sais que c'est des
basketteuses de qualité et si elle donne
une bonne préparation physique et peut
venir avec nous faire du cycle j'avais
ouvert c'est d'abord la caisse au
mondial si amère scintillation l'air
d'être bien mais tout ça voilà merci
beaucoup
thiery latt revenus et puis on suivra
aussi le la présentation du nouveau
maillot et puis c'est les prochaines et
au 30 juin au 30 juin la revancharde la
revanche a sonné nouvelle édition
toujours sur la colline d'elancourt la
colline ex colline de la revanche